tan solo minutos después de que el ato
el fuego entrara en vigor testigos
reportaron ataques aéreos y
enfrentamientos en la que es el más
reciente de un variado número de treguas
que fueron anunciadas y luego
incumplidas en cerca de seis semanas de
enfrentamientos ongs están impacientes
por un corredor que permita entregar
ayuda humanitaria y el enviado de la ONU
para Sudán pidió a las partes terminar
con la violencia
del fuego a corto plazo no es el
objetivo es un instrumento para seguir
adelante necesitaremos conversaciones
sobre un cese permanente de las
hostilidades y Tendremos que considerar
Y por supuesto apoyar un nuevo proceso
político
en el centro del conflicto está la lucha
por el poder entre el jefe del ejército
y el jefe del grupo paramilitar de
fuerzas de acción rápida los dos son
antiguos aliados que unieron fuerzas
para orquestar el golpe de 2021 hasta
que los planes para integrar a los
paramilitares en el ejército rompieron
las relaciones
el conflicto ha desplazado a casi 1,1
millones de personas internamente y
hacia los países vecinos